welcome to a new lecture on the binomial
theorem in this lecture we will look at
certain divisibility results which can
be derived based on binomial theorem so
once again recall the binomial theorem
is given by X plus y the whole power N
equals summation are equal to 0 to n see
our X power n minus r y power r where we
use CR to denote NCR so to give you a
flavor of the kind of results we'll be
looking at today let's look at the first
example which asks you to show that 3
power 2 n plus 2 minus 8 n minus 9 is
divisible by 64 when N is a natural
number so it asks you to show that this
term is still true by 64 for natural
numbers n so at first sight there
doesn't seem to be a binomial expansion
you can apply to generate this result so
we would like to create a binomial
expansion to derive this result and so
notice that you have you have an
exponent here but you also have some
terms here and these terms are in
general or do so by 64 for m being
natural numbers so you can plug in
certain natural numbers and you can see
that this this term which is being
subtracted from 3 power 2 and plus 2 is
not going to be divisible by 64 and so
we would like to somehow get rid of
these terms and leave the remaining term
to be do so by 64 so let's look at a way
of free expressing this term 3 power 2 n
plus 2 minus a 10-9 can be written as 9
power n plus 1 where I've just taken a
power of 2 into 3 and written 3 squared
is 9
you still have minus 8 8 and minus 9 so
now this looks a little more promising
because you have 9 power n plus 1 and
you have a 9 and you have an 8 n so you
can get rid of the 8n potentially by
writing 9 as 1 plus 8 raise this power n
plus 1 and you have a 10 minus 9 so this
looks a little more promising and now
you have a term which you can expand
using the binomial theorem so let's try
and expand this term so this is nothing
but n plus 1 C 0 times 1 power n plus 1
plus n plus 1 C 1 times 1 power n times
8 plus n plus 1 C 2 1 power n minus 1 8
square and so on so we will be concerned
about the higher order terms later and
we have still subtracting a 10 and 9
from this term so let's see how this
simplifies to so this is nothing but the
first term is 1 the second term is n
plus 1 times 1 times 8 and the remaining
terms can be so simply written as
summation R equal to 2 to n plus 1 and
plus 1 C R 1 power n plus 1 minus R + 8
power 5 and you still have to subtract a
10 and 9 from this expression so this
looks a little more promising because
notice that these first two terms add up
to exactly 8 and plus 9 and so you can
cancel these 2 terms and so you're just
left with summation R equal to 2 to n
plus 1 and
1 c1 power n plus 1 minus R is just 1
and you have 8 power 5 so this is what
we are left with and we want to show
that this is divisible by 64 so notice
that the summation runs from R equal to
2 so let's rewrite this as summation R
equal to 0 to n minus 1 and plus 1 C I
plus 2 8 power R plus 2 so we just use
this change of indices to rewrite this
summation and notice that there is an
eighth power to here you can pull that
out this is going to be 64 times
summation R equal to 0 to n minus 1 and
plus 1 C R plus 2 8 power 5 so you have
a 64 year and you wanted to show that
this term is divisible by 64 so that is
good so what we have to show is that
this term is an integer so that's all
that remains so that term is clearly an
integer because you have a summation of
several terms where each term is made up
of two integers themselves so 8th power
R is an integer and n plus 1 CR plus 2
again it's an integer so we have
summation of integers and so this term
is an integer so we have that this
overall term is divisible by 64 which is
the desired result so we've seen an
application of the binomial theorem
where we somehow we expressed our given
term in terms of in terms of an
expression where from there we could use
the binomial expansion and derive a
divisibility result for the original
term so let's look at a second example
this example asks to show that to power
4 n minus 2 power and time
seven n plus one is divisible by 196
whenever n is the natural number so this
example is very similar to the previous
one and once again we have to figure out
how to rewrite this original term in a
form which is amenable to the binomial
expansion so notice now that we want to
show that this term is therefore by 196
and 196 is nothing but 14 Square and you
have a 7 year and a 2 power n here so
that looks promising so let's see what
we can do so 2 power 4 n minus 2 power n
times 7 n plus 1 can be rewritten as 16
power n minus 2 power n times 7 n plus 1
where we just read it in 2 power 4 n 16
power n so now 16 can somehow be split
into 14 and 2 so we can rewrite this as
2 plus 14 power n minus 2 power n times
7 n plus 1 so this looks promising
because now we have a 14 appear in a
binomial term and we want to show that
this whole term social 196 which is 14
squared so let's go through the motions
again and use the binomial theorem to
show that this is nothing but NC 0 2
power n 14 power 0 plus NC 1 2 power n
minus 1 14 power 1 plus let's rewrite
the higher order terms the summation R
equal to 2 to N and C R to power n minus
r 14 power R and we subtract the
original to power n times 7 n plus 1
from this expansion
so once again you can rewrite this as 2
power n plus n times 2 power n minus 1
times 14 plus summation R equal to 2 to
n and CR to power n minus R 14 for R and
you still have to subtract 2 power n
times 7 and plus 1 so this is nothing
but 2 power M plus n times 2 power n
times seven that have factorized 14 as 2
times 7 and you have a resulting
summation R equal to 2 2 and then CR to
power n minus R 14 R and you subtract 2
power n times 7 n + 2 power n but I just
expanded this term so notice once again
that we can cancel the first two terms
with the terms being subtracted and
you're still left with you're only left
with this summation R equal to 2 to n n
CR to power n minus R 14 power now the
items are quite similar to the previous
one previous example we've seen so I
won't go through this in detail you can
just rewrite this as 14 square times
summation R equal to 0 to n minus 2 and
C R + 2 to power n - R
- - and 14 power
we're here you started with 2 power n
minus 2 and so you're starting back to
power n minus 2 again and here you
started with 14 squared and here you
start with 14 power 0 since I've pulled
out a 14 square here so so this is what
we are left with and notice that this
summation again is an integer and we
have the summation being multiplied by
14 square which is 196 which is again an
integer and we wanted to show that this
term is divisible by 196 so that's
exactly what we've shown since we
factorized it into a form where we have
a leading coefficient of 14 square and
so once again shown that this term is 2
by 196 whenever N is a natural number so
let's look at a multiple choice question
which is based on this flavor of
problems so the question asks you to
show ask you how when v power 99 is
divided by 13
the remainder yes so it asked you to
compute the remainder and 5 power 99 is
still divided by 13 and the options are
8 9 10 and none of these
so this is a kind of problem where it's
hard to eliminate the options without
actually solving the problem because if
you have none of these where so even if
you determine that this remainder is
going to be even or odd you're not
really sure whether it's option it is
since there's a none of these and even
if the remainder is odd you can't dis
conclude that the answer is 9 so you
would actually have to derive the result
for this example so let's see how you
can rewrite by 5 power 99 to obtain an
amenable result so to to arrive at this
the solution
let's try computing some powers of 5 to
see where that gets us so 5 power 1 is
Phi which is quite far from 13 so it's
not really much you can do about it
5 squared is 25 which is close to a
multiple of 13 13 times 2 is 26 so this
looks promising but 5 power 99 is not a
direct power of not an integral power of
Phi square and so let's try this
approach let's write 5 power 99 as 5
times 5 power 98 I just factorize - 99
into a more suitable form and now I can
write this is 5 times 5 power 5 square
power 49 and since I know that Phi
square is close to a multiple of 13 this
is nothing but 5 times 26 minus one
power 49 26 is a multiple of 13 so the
diversability results are going to be
fairly easy to derive so this is nothing
but five times and now you use the
binomial expansion of 26 minus 1 volt
power 49 so let's see how we can write
this
it's like 49 see 0 minus 1
power 4926 power zero so I'm starting
off with -1 power 49 and 26 power zero
since we are only concerned with the
power of 26 which is zero since all
other terms are going to be do so by 13
so and you have 49 see one minus one
power 48:26 power 1 plus so on so this
is going to be the expansion of 26 minus
one the whole power 49 and you have a
leading term which is Phi in this
expression so notice that all of these
higher powers as I mentioned are going
to be divisible by 13 and so since we
only care about the remainder that this
term leaves when divided by 13 we don't
really care about these terms which are
exactly doable by 13 so this is the only
remaining term is going to give us the
remainder when you divide 5.99 by 13 so
let's see what that gives us
that's 5 times 49 6 zeroes 1 times minus
1 power 49 is minus 1 times 26 power 0
is 1 and so this gives us minus 5 so the
remainder went 5 power 99 is they were
divided by 13 is minus 5 for those of
you who aren't used to this kind of
notation this might seem a little
strange that you get negative remainder
but to just get a positive remainder you
just add a multiple of 13 since we may
throw so many multiples of 13 you get a
negative number but if you add a
multiple of 13 you get 8 so the
remainder when 5.99 is divided by 13 is
8 so those of you who are familiar with
modular arithmetic can notice that the
approach we took is very similar to the
approach you take when use when you do
such kinds of problems in number theory
where you try to get try to get at a
power of 5 which is close to a multiple
of 13 and you just used remainder
arguments where you ignored terms which
were multiples of 13 and so you you're
only left with
one term since you only care about the
remainder so this is a sample of a
problem which could appear in an exam
type situation where you're asked to
derive a result based on the
divisibility of a term by a natural
number R using the binomial theorem so
that's it for this lecture hope you
enjoyed watching this lecture and in the
next lectures we will look at some
example problems based on the binomial
theorem I thank you for your attention
and hope you can join us next time